it's that time of year when some of us  give gifts but Microsoft will have some  treats for all of us come January I'm  Tony this is a game spot news update and  this is your games with gold January  lineup first up Xbox one is getting the  tower defense action RPG hybrid death  trap world of van helsing all month long  it's also getting fighting game killer  instinct season 2 from January sixteenth  through februari 15th the xbox 360 is  getting puzzle platformer the cave from  January first through the 15th and  another platformer Rayman Origins from  January sixteenth through the 31st any  of those sound good to you and those are  your games with gold for January 2017 if  you still haven't grabbed outlast from  december's lineup it'll still be  available through january fifteenth to  keep up with everything from both xbox  and microsoft you're already in the  right place